thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode mmm
tensors hollow clone what a
mathematician say about tensors a rake
and tensor in M dimensions is a
mathematical object with in indices and
M to the N components that obeys certain
transformation rules we can do better
than that this episode was made possible
by generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies if you're like me you find
definitions and text books incredibly
unsatisfying in their defence
definitions like this one are correct
complete and concise we call them the
three C's no one calls them that I call
them that
anyway kick correctness is absolutely
vital it doesn't matter how clear your
explanation is if it's wrong but the
other two are very flexible so let's see
what we can do by the end of the video
you should understand this definition
with all its math speak to get there
though we're gonna need a little context
cuz that is abstract is the word tensor
actually comes from an old latin word
meaning to stretch if you pull an object
outward along its length it experiences
something called tensile stress in
response its length increases which you
know makes sense except that's not the
only type of stress an object can
experience this cube could be stretched
or compressed along any of the three
spatial dimensions wouldn't a vector be
enough for that first a vector is a
tensor and second there are six other
stresses I haven't mentioned yet the
cube could also be sheared along those
directions that's nine possible stresses
yeah but can't we just add the forces
together along each direction no no we
can't each of these forces makes the
cube respond in a different way we have
to consider them all separately these
nine different stresses are usually
organized into a three by three matrix
called the stress tensor quick
disclaimer it's not a tensor because I
can write it as a matrix matrices and
tensors are not the same thing
a matrix is just a convenient way to
organize numbers sometimes writing the
stress tensor like this
we can see it clearly has nine
components but our definition mentioned
two specific properties rank and
dimension this cube is three dimensional
so any tensor describing its behavior
will also be three dimensional that's
why our stress tensor is organized into
three rows and three columns each
corresponds to a specific direction in
three-dimensional space seriously it's
that easy
rank is the amount of information you
need to find a specific component in
this case we only need a row and a
column that's two pieces of information
so we say the tensor is Rank 2 the
stress tensor is rank two and dimension
three matrix notation is pretty
convenient for rank two tensors of any
dimension with the electromagnetic field
tensor you still only need a row and a
column to find a specific component so
it's rank two however there are four
rows and four columns which means this
tensor is four dimensionals the
electromagnetic field tensor is rank two
and dimension 4 this notation starts to
fall apart with higher rank tensors
though
for example a rank 3 tensor requires
three pieces of information to find a
component wall this is still technically
a matrix the math operations aren't very
obvious it gets even worse with rank
four tensors this is certainly
interesting to look at but it's not very
useful honestly matrix notation is kind
of like a security blanket anyway if
it's only there to make people feel more
comfortable when they're first learning
about tensors then what are we supposed
to use index notation rank zero means
you don't need any information to find a
component that's just a scalar boring
rank one means we only need one piece of
information to find the component in
other words we only need one index
that's just a vector maybe something
like the velocity of a ball across a
table rank two means we need two pieces
of information or two indices
traditionally we use Latin letters for
two and three dimensions and Greek
letters for four dimensions which helps
make rank and dimension more obvious at
a glance rank three means three indices
rank four means four indices and so on
okay if fine but what makes them tensors
how they transform humans have a decent
intuition about velocity so let's start
there this ball could encounter some
wind which would slow it down but that's
not the kind of transformation we're
talking about we're not talking about
how the situation might change we're
talking about how the coordinate system
might change to use physics on this
scenario we need to assign a coordinate
system to it something like this that's
just a tool though we could just as
easily put the coordinates over here or
over here or even over here we could
have rotated them like this or like this
we could have even stretched or
compressed either of the axes but our
choice of coordinates should have no
effect on physical reality none of these
transformations will change the velocity
of the ball weight it wouldn't a
rotation change the direction no it's
still moving to the right but don't the
components change yes but that's just
how we're representing it now what it
actually is this vector is a rank one
dimension two tensor it has two
components one for each of the
dimensions any change in coordinates
will change the values of those
components but the physical nature of
that vector remains the same but
wouldn't any arrow do that actually no
take angular momentum for example if we
put our coordinates at the center of the
circular orbit the angular momentum
points up it's steady and constant but
if we shift the coordinates to the edge
of the circle that's no longer the case
the angular momentum changes over time
it even goes to zero for a brief moment
which is ridiculous that shouldn't
happen with a real physical thing so we
call angular momentum a false vector or
pseudo vector it has a direction so it
masquerades as a vector but it isn't
actually a vector
velocity is a real vector angular
momentum is not it's a pseudo vector if
a real vector is zero in one set of
coordinates it must be zero in all of
them no exceptions but doesn't velocity
go to zero if your coordinates move
along with the moving yes but that's not
a three-dimensional transformation
it's a four-dimensional one which means
you can't use three-dimensional vectors
this ball is moving relative to the
table but not relative to itself
shifting to a steadily moving coordinate
system is something we call a boost and
it requires we include time as an
additional axis this ball may be moving
through space but it's also moving
through time it has its own time axis we
call this space-time and a boost is just
a four dimensional coordinate rotation
but if we want to talk about velocity we
need a four dimensional velocity or a
four velocity which is a rank one
dimension four tensor
don't forget this video is still about
tensors this balls for velocity is a
real vector it remains the same under
these four d rotations just like regular
three velocity did under 3d rotations
you can't work in four dimensions
without using four-dimensional tensors
come on crazies the same goes for things
like the three-dimensional magnetic
field moving electric charge will
generate a magnetic field but only if
you see the charge moving if you're
moving along with it the charge is
stationary which means no magnetic field
the magnetic field is not a real vector
it's a pseudo vector that's why we came
up with the rank two electromagnetic
tensor it fixes this problem it's a real
tensor unfortunately a rank two tensor
can't be visualized as an arrow like a
vector can but it can be understood as a
transformation between vectors in fact
that's exactly what this equation says
about the e/m tensor it transforms the
four velocity of a charged particle into
a force a moving charged particle inside
of a force field
areas of force it's a little magical
isn't it okay let's use the stress
tensor instead fine I'm a huge dice nerd
I love dice the best ones are the
Platonic solids obviously let's consider
the four sided one the tetrahedron if we
want to know the force on one of its
surfaces we just need to know what
stress tensor maybe one of its surfaces
is facing this way if it's experiencing
stress described by this then our
surface is being nudged this way the
area vector is transformed into a force
vector so what's a tensor it's a number
or collection of numbers that maintains
its meaning under transformations if you
make a different choice in coordinates
the components of the tensor will change
but in a way that conspires to keep the
meaning of the tensor the same this
velocity vector is a Rank 1 tensor that
describes the motion of the ball
regardless of the coordinate choice this
stress tensor is a rank two tensor and
describes how to get a force from an
area regardless of the coordinate choice
if your number or collection of numbers
doesn't do that then it's not a tensor
it's a false tensor or pseudotensor not
being able to tell the difference can
get you into some serious trouble at
least in the math so got any questions
about tensors please ask in the comments
if you're looking for a deeper dive
check out the book I wrote it's got an
entire chapter explaining tensors and
it's available in paperback and as an
e-book thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy
if investing in your STEM skills is your
kind of new year's resolution you should
check out brilliant
maybe you're naturally curious or want
to build your problem-solving skills or
need to develop confidence in your
analytical abilities with brilliant
premium you can learn something new
every day
brilliance thought-provoking math
science and computer science content
helps guide you to mastery by taking
complex concepts and breaking them into
bite-sized to understand
chuck's there's a whole course on linear
algebra which is where matrices are
important there's even a course on 3d
geometry where you can learn about
platonic solids brilliant helps you
achieve your goals in stem one small
commitment to learning at a time if this
sounds like a service you'd like to use
go to brilliant org slash science asylum
today the first 200 subscribers will get
20% off an annual subscription I really
enjoyed some of the takeaways that
people got from my last video like that
the earth has only been around the
galaxy 20 times or that the galaxy has
only rotated somewhere between 50 and 60
times most of us would have expected
those numbers to be bigger you know
anyway thanks for watching
[Music]